police departments look at their
vehicles kind of like a shared resource
they run the cars around the clock
they're used by multiple officers and
that became a point of concern for the
NYPD during the peak of the pandemic
there is they had nearly 20% of their
uniformed officers out sick
NYPD asked Ford for help first
responders across the country racing to
emergencies now have the added danger of
potential exposure to coronavirus untold
thousands of emergency workers have
gotten sick paramedic Robert Emerson
showed us the gear he wears to a
possible Kovac call outside Detroit
we're putting these supplies on and
we're using them all day in New York
City the NYPD has lost at least 43
employees including six police officers
to the virus that has sickened more than
5,700 of its staff we have an invisible
enemy here NYPD Deputy Commissioner
Robert Martinez oversees the
department's 10,000 vehicles 85% are
used around-the-clock daily by multiple
officers with so many people going in
and out as well as in some cases we even
have perpetrators going in and out of
the vehicles that definitely gave us a
challenge to figure out the frequency of
cleaning vehicles and how to clean
vehicles the Chicago Police Department
has reported at least 538 coronavirus
infections this is how it disinfects
vehicles after a case is reported
cleaning supplies remain limited and
wiping down the cars between shifts can
miss things prompting the NYPD to ask
Ford if there's a way for the cruisers
to disinfect themselves we learned how
the virus degrades with temperature and
time within 40 days Ford engineers
working with researchers at Ohio State
University found a way to kill corona
virus by essentially baking 133 degrees
for 15 minutes inside the car can
provide up to a 99 percent reduction in
virus concentration using heat from the
engine they programmed the car's climate
control system to run a sanitization
cycle you can feel the hot air start to
come out of the car that first heats up
the vehicle and after those 15 minutes
of temperatures hotter than Death Valley
the AC kicks on to cool it back down we
got to keep our department strong so
they're able to do
need to do to keep the city safe this
would be a great tool to minimize the
transmission of the disease within the
vehicle this heat mode if you will is a
software update that's available now the
NYPD hopes to be using it as part of its
cleaning protocols as soon as this week
the cycle from heat up to cool down can
be done in as little as 45 minutes to an
hour